[Musique]
cinq cent mille personnes passent sur
cette route forestière chaque année le
département propose une nouvelle manière
de vivre cet itinéraire à travers une
application une réflexion collective sur
la meilleure manière de découvrir les
trois caldera c'est énorme effondrement
qui dessine le paysage est donc
désormais les gens vont se stationner à
peu près à 150 mètres du belvédère il va
y avoir un accès à pied
accès à pied c'est important puisqu'il y
aura plus de voitures des gens visuel à
côté du belvédère ça sera beaucoup plus
intimiste une meilleure immersion dans
le milieu naturel et les gens vont
traverser un petit cheminement qui a été
vraiment recrée avec soin par le nfp
autre élément important c'est
l'accessibilité aux personnes à mobilité
réduite qu'on a pu créer sur ce site
avec un travail commun encore une fin de
tous les sachants de toutes les
institutions techniques qui ont permis
de réaliser une d'une part une
application innovante
c'est la première application mobile
d'un itinéraire à la réunion et au
niveau des réalisations sur le terrain
une recherche d'une de la retour à la
naturalité des travaux qui ont été
réalisés uniquement avec des matériaux
d'origine des ménages de roche plainte
au fond c'est magnifique
[Musique]
révéler notre patrimoine prend alors
tout son sens historique botanique
géologique écologique cette
scénarisation vous permet de remonter le
temps de l'origine du volcanisme à nos
jours peut savoir que dans notre projet
de mandature nous avons placé les hauts
de l'île qui est la cinquième 5ème micro
région une zone à développer une zone
arrière vivre et aujourd'hui le travail
qui a été réalisé par l'om f
le département est aussi les autres
partenaires montrent bien que la volonté
elle est là elle est ambitieuse parce
que c'est une première et c'est un
projet totalement innovant pour le
département et aussi pour la réunion
entière le département propriétaire et
financeur est ainsi chef de file de tous
ces aménagements des espaces naturels
sensibles
un plan d'action ambitieux qui se
concrétisera en 2021
[Musique]